hallo Leute wir backen wir in
Adventskalender aus für richtige Männer
[Musik]
es tut mir extrem leid ich muss mich
selber hier gerade noch an diese
Situation
gewöhnen also jetzt nicht lachen nicht
lachen okay nicht lachen gut
wir packen Adventskalender für Männer
aus der Mens darf Adventskalender von
coolster Mensch darf ja Sachen Sachen
die Männer brauchen nee jetzt mal
ernsthaft hallo Leute hier ist wieder
eure mal wann und willkommen zu einem
neuen Adventskalender auspack Video
heute testen wir den Monster
Adventskalender ich habe schon öfter mal
Adventskalender für Männer getestet und
diesen Adventskalender habe ich auch bei
der Seite cool stuff gefunden wo ich
auch den Zuckerstangen Adventskalender
hier habe und ja es hat mich einfach
angesprochen ein Mensch darf
Adventskalender ich sehe jetzt hier aber
schon tolle Terry Adventskalender also
Sachen fürs Badezimmer dieser Kalender
hat nur ganze 30,95 € gekostet das
finden wir doch tip top das ist ja in
Ordnung aber ja toll ich weiß nicht was
für Beauty Produkte hier drin sein
sollten wenn es nicht renommierte Marken
sind die man irgendwie kennt dann finde
ich immer schwierig weil das ist dann
meistens made in China so z.B wie beim
Adventskalender da war glaube ich auch
alles so made in China normal ist für
Marken wie z.B auch essen ich glaube die
sind auch in China produziert
ich bin immer so ein Fan von man kennt
irgendwie die Marke man weiß irgendwas
über die Marke so ist es halt so ne okay
wird mit deinem maskulin body die
Aufmerksamkeit die er verdient jeden Tag
im Dezember hinter jedem Türchen
verbirgt sich eine Überraschung für
einen Kern Weihnachten frisch und
gepflegt der herkommen will es macht
nicht so viel Sinn dass ich ein Männer
Adventskalender auspack aber ich wollte
mal wissen
für Männer sind noch
typisch Drinks Grill Zubehör also dieses
wirklich klassische Männerbild was man
in der Gesellschaft im Kopf hat
ansonsten sind Frauen echt besser
aufgestellt was Adventskalender angeht
habe ich das Gefühl und jetzt nicht lang
schnacken Kopf in Nacken wir machen das
erste Türchen auf Türchen Nummer 1
männliches Schauer Gel ja cool das
riecht männlich ich weiß nicht was
dieser männliche Duft ist ist das
Moschus ist das ja es riecht halt wie
Duschgel für Männer made in China ja ja
diese Adventskalender Produkte die so
probemäßig hergestellt werden ich glaube
ich mag den jetzt schon nicht Nummer
zwei komm ich bin ein Kerl was brauche
ich im Badezimmer oh oh oh nein meine
Fingernägel sind viel zu lang
Mann
ich kriegs nicht raus ein Fuß Stein und
meine männliche Hornhaut von den Füßen
weg zu rubbeln natürlich auch gerne sehr
praktisch wenn man in der Badewanne ist
aber erst zum Schluss machen also so mit
dem Restwasser nicht in seinem Raspel
fußwasser drin liegen bleiben okay das
ist sehr wichtig
normal
drei diese Creme hat Hand und Fuß
Hand und foot Lotion kommen die da so
mit Französisch da drunter das ist so
geil made in China ursprünglich aus der
UK die kommen da ein mit so
französischer Beschreibung Lotion
Polymer elep klingt halt so als ob das
Mehrwert wäre
oh ja es riecht so oh oh hey capital bra
abgespritzt hier oh Gott please no 10
Minuten als fun Verkleidung weißes
Flecken so wie machen wir die Hand und
fußlotionen auf meine Hände ich halte
halt nicht viel von diesen billig
produzierten aber es macht was es soll
ne ich meine am Ende ist es Creme für
meine männlichen Hände mit einem Mann
zusammen das einzige was mir für Männer
Cosplay einfällt ist
über Männer Nummer vier oh nee das
Öffnen
oha und schwarzer lummerschwamm meine
Hautschuppen vom Körper abzuwaschen
Nummer 5 Nummer 5 haben wir ein Body
Scrub ja
was los sag doch sag doch hey hey
effizienter sehr effizienter in dem
Video redest
geh mit dir überall hin Schatz ja gut
ich mache jetzt nicht alles auf und Body
Scrubs ich glaube ich bin einfach ganz
happy wenn Timo das benutzt kann also
schön seine Haut pflegen ich werde den
Grund also ich werde die Preise für
diese Produkte nicht aussuchen weil das
ist
danke Nicola raus es ist ein
Adventskalender aus UK made in China ich
glaube nicht dass er Nikolaus was
krasses drin sein wird
schade das brauche ich tatsächlich ein
sehr praktisches item normal gut
verarbeitet oh ich muss meine
Geheimratsecken
stecken kann man immer gebrauchen ich
kenne aber tatsächlich kein Haushalt der
dieses Ding nicht hat ne
sieben Bodylotion klar braucht man auch
denk mal sie riecht wie alles andere
auch ja mensch das ist ein bisschen
boring das ist das fühlt sich an wie
wieder EMP Adventskalender für Frauen
damals dieser mit den ganzen China
Duschsachen
ich kriege es nicht raus da ist eine
Badebombe drin jetzt weiß ich an wen ich
mich erinnere ich gucke gerade Vampire
Diaries zum ersten Mal also ich sehe
nicht aus wie Damon aber mit diesem
schwarzen Hemd und diese Frisur so
leicht bisschen Dingen
Nummer 9 wird jetzt nichts Besonderes
drin sein was soll denn hier drin sein
oh es ist was Besonderes was ist das
Emery Boards oh
also das finde ich tatsächlich gar nicht
mal so und klug muss ich Timo an seinem
Platz da machen weil der ist so ein
fingernagelbeißer und dann kann er sich
die immer so schön abschleifen das muss
man eigentlich im Badezimmer machen ne
das ist halt nicht so nachhaltig wenn
man das also es wäre halt besser wenn
man einfach eine hat aber irgendwie
finde ich das für unterwegs so zum
Reisen und so ist es gar nicht schlecht
und das Design also ja sie machen hier
so ein bisschen einen auf Französisch
aber es ist sehr neutral und und so ja
jetzt bin ich gespannt vielleicht
überraschen Sie mich doch noch ein
bisschen Nummer zehn darf nicht fehlen
Duschgel
und das hier ist zum Gesicht waschen
wahrscheinlich auch mit dem gleichen
Duft das würde ich Timo jetzt nicht so
unbedingt obwohl auf jeden Fall alles
vegan nur die Frage ist
okay die hat jetzt keine gute Qualität
nee die Schere ist möglich ist richtig
scheiße also erwartet man jedes Türchen
hat ungefähr ein Wert von Euro das
erwartet man für ein Euro ne also sie
ist okay wahrscheinlich kann man sich
damit auch so ein bisschen die
Augenbrauen und wenn deine Nase
irgendwas schneiden ah die ist wirklich
gut zum nasenhaarschneiden hier vorne
nicht so spitze Dinger also tatsächlich
kann man sie auch gut zum ich dachte das
ist eine Nagelschere aber vielleicht ist
sie so ein bisschen universell
einsetzbar und dann ist es praktisch
dass sie vorne so stumpf ist Leute
dieses Video ist natürlich nicht
gesponnen sah dieses Videos nicht
gesponsert was ist das mit diesen
Produkten und dieses nicht rauskriegen
eine Reisezahnbürste wenn die Größen
sind ja auch eigentlich ganz gut das ist
eigentlich Zeug was in einem Reisegepäck
gehört ich bin auch schon mal Business
Class geflogen das ist auch das Zeug was
so in so einer Business Class Tasche
drin ist die man dann da vorne hat und
dann halt ja ein bisschen reisekram zu
haben 14 ich finde die sollten das so
deklarieren zum Reisen 15 es ist genau
der gleiche Kram wie bei diesem EMP
frauenkalender ich weiß nicht ob es
Frauen Kalender war aber ich glaube es
war Frauen Kalender genau diese Bürste
hatte ich nämlich schon mal in so einem
Kalender drin also wirklich praktisch
aber ich sage euch diese Bürste benutze
ich so oft und meine ist schon so
richtig so abgenutzt deswegen freue ich
mich gerade dass ich so eine neue habe
gerade wenn man so lange Fingernägel hat
wie ich ist das so geil beim da macht so
ein bisschen Seife dran dann kannst du
so richtig deine Fingernägel auch
schruppen und da drunter und sauber du
kriegst deine Hände so richtig sauber
wird das behalte ich und wenn Männer in
der Werkstatt waren und wieder irgendwas
gebastelt
dann machen Sie sich danach diese Hände
sauber 16 komm wir haben doch gerade
handwasch gehabt schwarze Seife
ja man braucht zwei 18
jährigen cream die übrigens mein Bad
gesehen sind keine angeklebten Haare das
ist mein Bad Flammen den ich immer habe
wer ist eigentlich immer ganz hell und
dann habe ich einfach nur Wimperntusche
drüber gemacht und zack kambad okay aber
noch Schatten und sowas gemacht aber
also gerade hier hinten hat das richtig
gut funktioniert
19 oh
Mensch schlimm für die Finger Nägel also
ich werde damit einfach Timos
Reisetasche ausstatten er hat immer so
eine Kulturtasche wo er alles da packe
ich ihm das alles rein so wir sind in
den 20ern angekommen Badesalz 21 ich
weiß nicht was es ist muskelz Muffins
Zug das ist klar ganz klar Muskel
Muskeln entspannungscreme das ist auch
so ein Quatsch 22 noch eine Seife 23
oh oh doch die funktioniert gut und das
war es auch schon wir sind bei der 24
angekommen es ist Weihnachten wir freuen
uns weil anscheinend die Person die uns
diesen Kalender geschenkt hat möchte
wohl sagen wir gehen auf eine Reise und
jetzt sind hier die Tickets drin wohin
es geht so ganz random nachdem rasieren
Creme also wenn man in einem etwas
teureren Hotel ist dann gibt's ja auch
diese Sachen dann stehen die da immer
morgens so und dann kann man sie
benutzen das hat so den ganzen Weib
davon ich finde es gut wenn man wirklich
glaube ich vor hat mit jemandem zu
verreisen also man schenkt z.B jemanden
zu Weihnachten Reise dann wäre dieser
Kalender schon mal so dass der da drauf
hinarbeitet wenn ich den jetzt aber Timo
einfach so gekauft hätte der hat halt
sein Shampoo oder sein Duschgel was er
gerne benutzt der benutzt meine Pinzette
der hat seine eigene Nagelschere
Nagelfeile hat jetzt nicht und so ein
Schwämmchen jetzt auch nicht deswegen
also es ist jetzt nicht verschwendet
weil ich weiß dass das meiste davon
einfach in seine Reisetasche kommt und
das nächste Mal wenn er danach Reisen
geht hat er alles irgendwie dabei aber
ja
nee also es ist wirklich es sind Reise
es ist ein der ein Mann geht auf eine
Reise wir sind alle immer auf einer
Reise die Reise des Lebens zum Glück
waren ja nur 30 € aber oder für jemanden
der gerade frisch ausgezogen ist ist das
bestimmt auch
erwartet habe also ich bin jetzt nicht
enttäuscht mit meiner Erwartung jetzt
nicht so hoch waren aber ich habe
irgendwie gedacht hier sind so ein
bisschen mehr verschiedene Sachen drin
die genießen noch mal ganz kurz diesen
Anblick
und wir sehen uns dann das nächste Mal
wieder wenn euch mein Umstyling gefallen
hat dann zeigt mir gerne mit einem
Daumen nach oben schreibt mir gerne in
die Kommentare wie euch dieser Kalender
gefallen hat und ob ihr noch Kalender
Vorschläge habt ich habe schon einige
bestellt und in der Pipeline aber ich
bin immer offen für neue Vorschläge und
dann sehen wir uns das nächste mal
wieder tschüss eure Vanessa geht's jetzt
erstmal ein Bier trinken mit meinem
Freund
wiedersehen